[Musique]
la maison a été fujitas c'est la
dernière demeure du peintre
franco-japonais Léonard Fujita qui l'a
habité dans les années 60 de 1960 à 1968
à Saint-Maur
c'est un lieu de mémoire qui permet en
fait de rentrer dans l'intimité de cet
artiste et d'apprécier les différentes
facettes de son art puisqu'il a été
peintre mais il y a aussi été céramiste
couturier destinataire et illustrateur
de l'ouvrage
du coup j'étais il découvre
villiers-le-bach et de manière générale
la vallée de la mérontaise qui se trouve
juste à côté par l'intermédiaire d'un
ami peintre japonais lui aussi qui
s'appelle Yasser tabouchi et qui
habitait dans les environs et c'est par
l'intermédiaire de cette amie que il a
découvert cette maison à
Villiers-le-Bâcle et qu'il en a fait
l'acquisition
la maison a téléphoné Fujita est ouverte
toute l'année et ses visites toute
l'année en semaine sur rendez-vous et
librement les weekends les samedis et
dimanches après-midi donc toute l'année
on accueille des groupes de scolaires
des groupes du champ social pour des
visites et nous avons une saison de
culturel qui s'étend de mai à septembre
et qui se calme que sur les grands
événements nationaux tel que la Nuit
européenne des musées ou encore des
Journées européennes du patrimoine
[Musique]
à l'occasion de cet événement nous
proposons aujourd'hui
des ateliers de pratiques artistique
mais aussi parfois des concerts ou du
spectacle vivant donc aujourd'hui pour
les Journées européennes du patrimoine
2023 nous accueillons en résidence un
artiste chorégraphe qui s'appelle et tu
présentes ce week-end des petits
tableaux qui sont inspirés de la vie de
Fujita il s'est associé avec des
artistes de cirque des danseurs et des
musiciens et livre plusieurs
représentations au fil de l'après-midi
on accueille aussi plusieurs ateliers de
pratiques artistique donc ce sont des
techniques qui sont inspirées de
l'univers de Fujita donc il y a de la
gravure il y a de la céramique il y a de
l'origami ou du manga
le lien de la maison avec le territoire
c'est essentiellement à travers le
public puisque on accueille un public
qui est local on accueille beaucoup de
scolaires qui viennent des environs et
on essaie de créer du lien avec le
territoire avec la mairie de
villiers-le-bâque mais aussi avec le
plateau de Saclay qui est tout proche
[Musique]